I'd like to start the topic with an
essential one. Even myself, I'm not 100%
sure of the implications of the terms
and
could you shed some light on these uh
terms for us? Alhamdulillah.
The word
it is derived from the Arabic word sah
which means the later part of the night
and its plural is called as ashar.
And Arabic word sahur means a meal which
is taken just before the break of dawn.
And the Arabic word sahur is the act of
taking the meal sahur. So sur is the act
and sahur is the pre-dawn meal. As far
as the Arabic wordar is concerned, the
wordar is derived from the Arabic word
fat which means to tear or which means
to break. And the word faturur means the
meal taken to break the fast. And the
Arabic wordar means the act of taking
the meal to break the fast.